urology specialists of nevada part of
optimcare the sponsors of the segment
want to remind men about the best ways
to take care of themselves especially
this month
happy men's health month it is
officially june i know you were saying
it's men's health month every month for
you but especially in june
absolutely yeah every month for us in
urology but this month is men's health
months officially yeah and we're
spreading awareness about how men should
be taking care of themselves so let's
just start with some quick basic
knowledge of men's health
sure so according to cdc data about 13
of men over age 20 years old have
significant health issues
and about 40 percent are obese
importantly even over half of men 52
percent
do have high blood pressure
the leading cause of death in men is
actually heart disease
cancer and
more recently coded 19 believe it or not
and then in urology these health issues
manifest in many ways and we see
a multitude of issues related to men's
health issues and problems and what are
some of the common
issues you're seeing in urology for men
the most common issues include
prostatitis erectile dysfunction
low testosterone infertility and
male
incontinence
prostatitis
and prostate problems comes in in two
forms
prostate issues include benign prostatic
hyperplasia and also as mentioned before
prostatitis these are similar uh
symptoms including frequency urgency
sometimes pain in the lower pelvic area
the benign prostatic hyperplasia happens
more slowly and the prostatitis happens
more rapidly what steps can men take to
improve their health a senior doctor a
primary care doctor initially for
initial screening and urologists can
address specific issues um it is
critical but in general
men can improve their health quite a bit
starting early
more physical activity
is very important
moving more
at any age getting the heart rate up
every day is very important
about 150 minutes of
of exercise getting the heart rate up a
week is actually recommended by the cdc
in addition resistance training about
two times a week as the muscles start to
slow down with aging is very important
it's very important also to have a
healthy diet um when you look at your
plate it's it's ideal to have about
two-thirds of your plate with green
leafy vegetables about a small
percentage with with complex
carbohydrates like grains or starches
potatoes and about a home size amount of
protein of your choice in every plate
and then importantly it's it's
critical not to get neglect sleep most
testosterone
in men and human growth hormone is
actually produced in the deepest stages
of sleep so both sleep quantity and
quality is really important and tends to
get worse as we age getting that seven
to nine hours of actual sleep a night
getting the quality of sleep is is very
critical
thank you to the urology specialists of
nevada part of optumcare for sponsoring
this segment they have four locations
across southern nevada for more
information call 702 8770
or visit usonb.com
[Music]